قالت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين واسرائيليين ان البنتاجون يرسلوا
بخير لاوكرانيا من مخزونته في اسرائيل
وكوريا الجنوبيه لتلبيه حاجه اوكرانيا
الماسه من قذائف المدفعيه وذكر المسؤولون
ان استخدام المخزونات الامريكيه في
اسرائيل جاء بسبب عدم تمكن صانعي الاسلحه
الامريكيه من مواكبه وتيره العمليات
القتاليه الاوكرانيه وان الولايات المتحده
وعدت اسرائيل بتجديد مخزناتها من الدخائر
التي يتم شحنها
ينضم الي من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري مرحبا وليد كيف يتفاعل هذا
الخبر داخل اسرائيل
من ان يؤدي ذلك الى غضب روسي قد ينعكس على
مساله التنسيق العسكري بين اسرائيل وروسيا
بالاجواء السوريه لذلك هذا القلق وكما جاء
على لسان مصادر نقلت عنها الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ذلك يخشون من ان نقل نحو
300,000 قذيفه من المخازن الامريكيه
العسكريه في اسرائيل الى اوكرانيا من
شانها ان يؤدي الى توتر في العلاقه مع
موسكو لان في السابق اسرائيل كانت تكتفي
بارسال فقط ما هي امور دفاعيه او وقائيه
همم مثل همم
الحاميه وايضا
السترات الواقيه وما شابه اي مساعدات
وضعتها في اطار المساعدات الانسانيه الى
اوكرانيا رغم انها تعرضت لانتقادات عاليه
وكبيره من الرئيس
اوكراني زينسكي هذه المره الجديد ان
الاداره الامريكيه او الجيش الامريكي نقل
نقل وينقل من مخازينه الكثيره في اسرائيل
اسلحه حديثه الى اوكرانيا لمساعده الجيش
الاوكراني ومن يناصره هناك في مواصله
الحرب ضد روسيا وهو ما تخشى اسرائيل ان
يتسبب فعلا بتوثير العلاقه وبالتالي يؤدي
الى غضب الروسي قد تنتقم من خلاله روسيا
بالحد من حريه حركه الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في الاجواء السوريه هذا ما
يغضبهم لكن اللافت هذه المره ايضا ان
مصادر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الحالي من
يمين نتنياهو سرعت الى تسريب خبر من ان
الموافقه على السماح للجيش الامريكي بنقل
هذه القذائف هي جاءت من رئيس الحكومه
السابق يعيد لبيد وليس من نتنياه هو ما
يشير الى ان نتنيه ويعده الذريعه التي قد
يسوقها لبوت فيما اذا بال تفاعلت القضيه
وادت الى مثل هذا الغضب للجيش الامريكي
مخازن كبيره من الاسلحه في اسرائيل عدا عن
المخازن المشتركه وكانت في كثير من
الاحيان وفي حروب مع العرب كانت تلجا
اسرائيل او كان الامريكيون يسمحون لها
باستخدام هذه الذخيره المعده اصلا لاهداف
الاستراتيجيه امريكيه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط على وجه الخصوص هذه المره استخدمت
من اجل دعم اوكرانيا وهو ما قد يؤدي وفق
مصادر اسرائيليه الى قلاق وهناك الى غضب
وهو ما يسيروا قلق في اسرائيل من انه قد
ينعكس بالفعل على العلاقات مع موسكو بما
يتعلق وتحديدا الملف السوري
وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت همم
معنا من رام الله شكرا جزيلا